so we are asked to order the expressions
from least to greatest and this is from
the exercises on khan academy and if
we're doing it on khan academy we would
drag these little tiles around from
least to greatest least on the left
greatest on the right i can't drag it
around because this is just a picture so
i'm going to evaluate each of these and
then i'm going to rewrite them from
least to greatest so let's start with 2
to the third minus 2 to the first what
is that going to be 2 to the third minus
2 the first and if you feel really
confident just pause this video and try
to figure out the whole thing order them
from least to greatest
well 2 to the third that is 2 times 2
times 2
and then 2 to the first well that's just
2.
so 2 times 2 is 4 times 2 is 8.
minus 2
this is going to be equal to 6. so this
expression right over here could be
evaluated as being equal to 6.
now what about this right over here what
is this equal to
well let's see we have
squared plus 3 to the 0. 2 squared is 2
times 2
and anything to the 0 power is going to
be equal to one it's an interesting
thing to think about what zero to the
zero power should be but that'll be a
topic for another video but here we have
three to the zero power which is clearly
equal to one and so we have two times
two plus one this is four
plus one which is equal to five so the
second tile is equal to five
and then three squared well three
squared that's just three times three
three times three is equal to
nine
so if i were to order them from least to
greatest the smallest of these is
2 squared plus 3 to the 0 power that one
is equal to 5. so i'll put that on the
left
then we have this thing that's equal to
6 two to the third power minus two to
the first power
and then the largest value here is three
squared
so we would put that tile
three
squared we will put that tile on the
right and we're done